People try to say, well, you
should try to learn 10 words a day
and really make sure you can use
them and sort of nail them down.
I've never found that effective.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I wanna talk about learning
vocabulary and why we shouldn't
try to remember vocabulary.
Now, if you enjoy my videos,
please subscribe, click on
the be for notification.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I mentioned the other day that
I went to visit my brother who's
not well, he's sort of bedridden.
I gave him an iPad and I tried
to get him going on LingQ.
So it's very interesting for me,
and I speak to him every couple of
days, it's very interesting for me
to see his experience because he's
not an experienced language learner.
And so he's learning LingQ and
he's getting used to learning
in his case Spanish using LingQ.
And so he said to me on several
occasions, I keep on trying to remember
this sentence or this word, and I can't
remember it, then it's quite frustrating.
And so I try to explain to him
again that, you know, don't
worry about not remembering.
In fact, don't even try to remember
the vocabulary, keep moving,
keep moving on and eventually
the words will start to stick.
And I thought of my own process
of language learning and, I mean,
the bulk of my words I learn them
through listening and reading.
Um, I look words up every time.
Like if I'm on my lesson page in
LingQ, if it's a blue word, obviously
I look it up in order to get the
meaning, it's now a yellow word.
But when I come across a yellow word, even
if I kind of think I know the meaning,
I'll just give another quick look.
Uh, and then of course, that
doesn't mean I can use it.
It doesn't mean that I won't, again, have
to look it up the next time, but it's
part of that gradual process of getting a
sense of what the scope of meaning of the
word is as I see it in different contexts,
getting familiar with the word, the word
getting familiar with me, and, and at some
point it starts to click in and it's very
hard to predict when that's gonna happen.
And so most of my activity is listening
and reading, noticing things while
reading, noticing things while listening
but I also do review words in list.
Uh, and I've said that I'll sometimes
pick, you know, the status three, the sort
of familiar words to try and move some
to known to pad my known words number.
Uh, I'll sometimes look at them
in alphabetical order just to see
the words that have the same, you
know, prefix, because that can help.
Uh, if I do flashcards, I want all the
information on the face of the flashcard.
It's all just exposure.
I don't try to rack my brain.
In other words, have the...
either the word in the target language
on the front of the flashcard, and then
try to think what it means and flip
it over, or conversely to see, say the
English word and try to remember what
that is, uh, in the target language.
I don't do those things.
Some people do.
I'm not saying that it's not
effective for some people, but
for me, I don't believe in it.
I, I, I feel that if I can continue
to expose myself or expose these
words to my brain in different
ways eventually I will learn them.
And I have noticed that a lot of the words
that I learned that are added to my known
words total are words that I didn't even
look up because words, you know, they
have things in common and pretty soon
we know, uh, maybe a different tense or
a different person or a different form
of a word that we've already learned.
And so without even looking that word
up, it's just added to our known words
total because we didn't save it and
so the system considers it known.
So I sometimes feel that this sort of
deliberate attempt to acquire words
and what's particularly bad is, is,
is if people try to say, well, you
should try to learn 10 words a day
and really make sure you can use
them and sort of nail them down.
I've never found that effective.
I far rather just expose myself to
as many words as I can rereading old
lessons, you know, going into new lessons,
exposing myself to these words and
gradually low and behold the statistics
in increase and my known words total
all of a sudden it's 10,000 words.
Granted, the way we count them at LingQ
where each form of the word is considered
a different word, but the point is
don't in my view, don't rely on memory.
Like a lot of people say to me,
well, I can't learn languages
because, uh, I have a poor memory.
Your poor memory is probably
not that poor, it's irrelevant.
Language learning is
not about memorization.
Language learning is about
committing yourself to a
process, enjoying the process.
Allowing the language to come into
you and trusting that your brain will
gradually understand more and more,
gradually acquire more and more words.
So my advice on language learning, or
in, in terms of acquiring words, and I
should say, accumulating words is the
fundamental task in language learning.
And so the more words you have
even passively the better your
potential in the language.
So it is important to acquire the
words, but you're not necessarily
gonna acquire words by deliberately
trying to remember them.
Uh, a couple of videos I'll leave you with
one where I talk about learning a hundred
words a day and another one where I talk
about memorization and language learning.
I did these a few years ago.
Hopefully I said the same
things then as I'm saying now.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.